Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Four, Episode Three: the EU's institutions, and the Council of Europe.
Who actually makes the decisions in the EU?
The most important EU institutions are: one, the European Commission.
Two, the European Parliament.
Three, the European Council, also called the EU summits.
Four, the Council of the European Union, in short the Council or the Council of Ministers.
And five, the EU Court of Justice.
The short version is that it is the main rule that the European Commission puts forward proposals for new EU legislation.
It is then the Council and the European Parliament that jointly adopt, change or reject the proposal.
Denmark is represented in the EU in different ways in these institutions.
First, the European Commission.
Like the other member countries in the EU, Denmark sends one commissioner to the European Commission.
The European Commission today has 27 members.
The Commission is to come up with concrete proposals for new legislation.
It must also take other initiatives that can put the overall political objectives of the treaties and the EU summits into effect.
The European Commission has both the right and the duty to propose new legislation to carry out EU policy.
The European Commission also checks whether the member countries comply with EU legislation.
If a country does not, the Commission can bring a case against that country at the EU Court of Justice.
The individual members of the Commission are appointed by the individual member countries for a five-year period and must function independently of the member countries they come from.
That means they are only to work for the EU's interests and not for that member country.
Like the Danish ministers, they have responsibility for each their own area.
For example, there is a commissioner for the economy and productivity, a commissioner for climate, a commissioner for agriculture and food, a commissioner for defence and space, a commissioner for fisheries and oceans, and so on.
Denmark's EU commissioner has since 2024 been Dan Jørgensen, born 1975, from the Social Democrats, who was previously a member of the European Parliament and climate minister in Denmark.
He is commissioner for energy and housing.
If an older exam asks who the Danish commissioner is, the answer used to be Margrethe Vestager; today it is Dan Jørgensen.
In the period 2014 to 24, Margrethe Vestager, born 1968, from the Social Liberal Party, who was earlier minister for economic and interior affairs in Denmark, was appointed as Danish commissioner.
Margrethe Vestager was vice president of the Commission and commissioner for competition policy in the EU.
To help propose and carry out EU legislation, the EU commissioners have a large administration, which resembles the Danish ministries.
In the EU they are called directorates-general.
Second, the European Parliament.
The European Parliament is the directly elected assembly in the European cooperation, since its members are elected by the citizens of the EU's member countries.
The European Parliament functions overall as a kind of legislative authority in the EU.
It resembles the Danish Folketing, but has more limited power.
For example, the European Parliament cannot levy tax.
The European Parliament adopts new legislation on the basis of proposals from the European Commission.
In addition, the European Parliament must among other things also adopt the EU's expenditure budget.
The European Parliament consists of 720 members from the 27 EU countries.
Each country has a number of seats that reflects the country's population.
Denmark has 15 members in the European Parliament, while big countries like Germany, France and Italy have a larger number of members.
Elections to the European Parliament are held every five years.
The members of the European Parliament are grouped in parties or groups on the basis of their political views, and not by which country they come from.
The Danish members of the European Parliament are therefore spread across a conservative group, a social democratic group, a liberal group, a green group and other groups.
The latest election to the European Parliament was held in June 2024.
As a result, the 15 Danish members are distributed among the following parties: the Socialist People's Party, SF, 3.
The Social Democrats 3.
Venstre 2.
The Conservative People's Party 1.
The Denmark Democrats 1.
The Social Liberal Party 1.
The Red-Green Alliance 1.
Liberal Alliance 1.
The Danish People's Party 1.
And the Moderates 1.
The Alternative also stood in the election, but did not get enough votes to be elected.
Third, the European Council, the EU summits.
The Danish prime minister meets with the other heads of government in the EU at EU summits in the European Council.
Here the leaders lay down the overall political framework for the cooperation in the EU.
They also make decisions on other important political questions.
That can for example be about the EU's enlargement, the EU's treaties or the EU's policy on the global stage.
Decisions are, as a main rule, made by consensus.
Fourth, the Council, the Council of the European Union, in Danish Rådet for Den Europæiske Union, or Ministerrådet.
In the Council, the member states' ministers from the member countries' governments meet at regular intervals.
That is why this institution is also often called the Council of Ministers.
The Council thus in practice consists of changing sector ministers, one from each country.
When, for example, something concerning the environment is to be discussed and adopted, it is the 27 environment ministers who meet.
If it concerns the internal market, the business ministers meet.
And if a proposal for EU legislation concerning agriculture is on the agenda, the food ministers meet.
The Council legislates together with the European Parliament.
That means adoption of EU legislation as a starting point requires support from both the Council and the European Parliament.
In a few areas, however, the European Parliament must only be consulted, while it is the Council that makes the final decision.
The different countries in the EU also take turns holding a so-called presidency.
This goes in turns every six months, and the country that has the EU presidency leads the meetings of the Council and a long series of committees.
The last Danish EU presidency was in 2025.
Do not confuse this with Denmark's seat on the UN Security Council in 2025 to 26, which is a seat, not a presidency.
Fifth, the EU Court of Justice.
Like the other countries in the EU, Denmark has one judge in the Court of Justice of the European Union, in everyday speech often called the EU Court.
The EU Court's task is to ensure that EU legislation is complied with.
The court can, among other things, settle conflicts between two member countries, and between the EU and the individual member country.
The EU Court can also decide how the EU rules are to be understood.
If a national court in a member country is in doubt about that, it can ask the EU Court.
Now, a very different organisation with a confusingly similar name: the Council of Europe.
Denmark has been a member of the Council of Europe since it was established in 1949.
In 1949, the Council of Europe consisted of ten Western European democracies.
Today, 47 European states are members.
The Council of Europe is not an EU institution.
It is an independent organisation in Europe.
The Council of Europe is thus a completely different institution from the European Council.
Before a country can become a member of the Council of Europe, it must recognise its citizens' personal and political rights of freedom.
The purpose of the Council of Europe is to ensure close cooperation between its member countries in a long list of political areas.
The aim is also to develop European democracy.
Russia was suspended from the Council of Europe after the attack on Ukraine in 2022.
The Council of Europe is, among other things, behind the drawing up of the European Convention on Human Rights from 1950.
It has also set up a court in the area of human rights, the European Court of Human Rights, which is to ensure that the convention is complied with.
By acceding to the convention, Denmark has committed itself to comply with the fundamental freedoms and human rights.
That means, among other things, freedom of expression, assembly and religion.
In 1992, the Convention on Human Rights was formally incorporated into Danish law.
It thereby stands on a par with other laws in Denmark, but below the constitution.
Denmark has at the same time recognised that individuals, under certain conditions, can bring a case against Denmark before the European Court of Human Rights.
Here is your recap for Episode Three.
There are five EU institutions, in Danish Europa-Kommissionen, Europa-Parlamentet, Det Europæiske Råd, Rådet for Den Europæiske Union, and EU-Domstolen: the Commission, the Parliament, the European Council, the Council of Ministers, and the Court of Justice.
The Commission proposes legislation; the Council and the Parliament adopt it.
The Commission has 27 members, one per country, appointed for five years.
Denmark's commissioner since 2024 is Dan Jørgensen, for energy and housing; Margrethe Vestager was commissioner 2014 to 24.
The Parliament has 720 members, 15 from Denmark, elected every five years; the latest election was in June 2024.
The European Council is the heads of government, deciding by consensus.
The Council presidency changes every six months; the last Danish presidency was in 2025.
Denmark has one judge in the EU Court.
The Council of Europe is not an EU institution: Denmark has been a member since 1949, there are 47 members, and it produced the European Convention on Human Rights of 1950, which became part of Danish law in 1992.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
Who does the Council of the European Union consist of?
Option A: Politicians directly elected by the EU's populations.
Option B: Civil servants appointed by the EU Commission.
Option C: Ministers from the member states' governments.
[DA] Hvem består Rådet for Den Europæiske Union af?  A: Politikere direkte valgt af EU’s befolkninger  |  B: Embedsmænd udpeget af EU-Kommissionen  |  C: Ministre fra medlemsstaternes regeringer
The answer is C: Ministers from the member states' governments.
It appeared in the May 2023 and November 2024 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: Ministre fra medlemsstaternes regeringer
Question 2.
Who does the European Parliament consist of?
Option A: Civil servants appointed by the EU Commission.
Option B: Ministers from the member states' governments.
Option C: Politicians directly elected by the EU's populations.
[DA] Hvem består Europa-Parlamentet af?  A: Embedsmænd udpeget af EU-Kommissionen  |  B: Ministre fra medlemsstaternes regeringer  |  C: Politikere direkte valgt af EU’s befolkninger
The answer is C: Politicians directly elected by the EU's populations.
It appeared in the November 2023 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: Politikere direkte valgt af EU’s befolkninger
Question 3.
Are the members of the European Parliament directly elected by the populations of the EU's member countries?
Option A: Yes.
Option B: No.
[DA] Er Europa-Parlamentets medlemmer direkte valgt af befolkningerne i EU’s medlemslande?  A: Ja  |  B: Nej
The answer is A: Yes.
It appeared in the November 2025 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: Ja
Question 4.
Where did Margrethe Vestager work in the period 2014 to 24?
Option A: The UN.
Option B: NATO.
Option C: The EU.
[DA] Hvor har Margrethe Vestager arbejdet i perioden 2014-24?  A: FN  |  B: NATO  |  C: EU
The answer is C: The EU.
It appeared in the May 2025 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: EU
That's the end of this part.
Well done.